Hi, Winnie. I love you.
Where's Winnie?
Probably in the bed.
You coming?
You a nice dude?
She's really gonna run it.
Where is she?
I don't know.
I thought she was about to come around the corner.
I don't think she's under the bed.
Maybe she's in the closet?
Yeah, probably.
Winnie?
Look in the corner.
Where?
Right in there.
No way she's in there.
Where the fuck is she at?
She's not under the bed?
I don't think so. Wait.
Oh. No, she's not under the bed.
She's right there.
Where?
Right there.
Oh.
Oh my god.
She mad?
Probably that she's losing that fucking carrier and now we're leaving.
What is under this bed, Gabrielle?
A blow-up mattress.
Core of...
Winnie!
Look, this thing's got a little light.
So you can see under there.
Oh.